بينما كان بوتا يزور حليفه لوكاسينكو في
بيلاروسيا كان زنسكي يزور جنوده على اخطر
جبهات القتال المستعار في اوكرانيا اختلاف
الرسائل والقوه في حرب لا يعرف احد حتى
الان كيف ومتى واين ستنتهي بالامس زاره
بوتن بيلاروسيا واجره محدثات مع نظيره
وحليفه الكسندر لوكيشنكو فيما يشارك الجيش
الروسي في مناورات تكتيكيه هناك الاكيد ان
الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل حالته اذ اقر بوتن
ان الوضع صعب جدا في المناطق الاربعه في
جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا التي اعلنت موسكو ضمها
دون سيطره عليها بالكامل
وفي دنيا اسكندريه اسكندريه
بشده وتحديد هويه الخونه والجواسيس
والمخربين بشكل انفعال
استغفر الله
روسيا تواجه اليوم تحديات كبيره وصعبه
تمسوا سيادتها ويجب التصدي لها لذلك روسيا
ممتنه لكل الجنود والضباط الذين اظهروا
شجاعه استثنائيه للدفاع عن وطنهم واداء
واجبهم العسكري في العمليه الخاصه ذلك
الواجب سيساعد في اقامه حياه طبيعيه
وسليمه للمواطنين في المناطق الجديده من
روسيا
كانت الزياره مختلفه فزياره بوتن تسرب على
انها استعداد لدخول بلا روسيا للحرب الى
جانب موسكو بينما في اوكرانيا زار الرئيس
بول
ساخنه شرق البلاد لدعم جنود بلاده المكتب
الاعلامي للرئاسه الاوكرانيه اكتفى بالقول
الناس التقى عسكريين وتحدث اليهم وقلد
الجنود او سببه الرجل وان كان يزور
بانتظام مناطق تقع قرب خط الجبهه الا ان
توجهها الى بخموت في منطقه دون بس ينطوي
على خطوره هي الاكبر زياره علق عليها نائب
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ميخائيل وفيدوروف
عبر التلغرام بالقول نازل نسكي في بخمته
الرئيس الاكثر شجاعه للامه للاكثر شجاعه
[موسيقى]